Jodie Sweetin gives John Stamos's new  girlfriend the fuller house stamp of  approval  she is delightful earlier this month ET  confirmed the fifty two-year-old is  dating model and actress Caitlyn McHugh  have mercy  according to Stamos is fuller house  co-star his new leading lady gets a big  thumbs up I actually met her a couple  days ago she is really sweet and she's  we are welcoming her into the family  yeah she looks very cute and they look I  we saw the video of them just sharing  ice cream it was very very cute yeah  they're they're adorable and we really  like her fingers crossed we'll get to  see Stamos and his gal pals supporting  sweet'n at a taping of Dancing with the  Stars the 34 year old actress revealed  many of her co-stars are planning to  come by think Andrea Barbie plays Kimmy  is coming next week Candice is gonna try  to make it David and his wife are coming  and John and Bob everybody's coming to  support I'm really excited